welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and if scary
stories to tell in the dark is keeping
you up tonight then why not watch one
more YouTube video that covers the film
and the creatures that inhabit it
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the monsters and scary stories to
tell in the dark including their
appearance in the movie and their
callbacks to the source material there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't seen the movie yet or don't want
any more nightmares then I highly
recommend that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video now let's
get into my breakdown of all the
monsters and scary stories to tell in
the dark ok so first of his Harold who
has pretty much become the face of the
marketing for the movie whilst the
character looks extremely close to his
characterization in the original source
material is actually a lot that differs
in the on-screen depiction in the
literature Harold was created by two cow
farmers named thomas and alfred who
named him after a boy that they hated
and they pretty much used him as a
punching bag one day Harold came to life
and he decided to torment the to farmers
who managed to escape from him with
their cows however when they realized
that they'd forgotten their milking
stools thomas was forced to return to
the bomb after drawing the short straw
alfred waits and waits and waits for him
but when he does not return he goes
looking for him only to see Harold on
the roof of their house holding Thomas's
corpse in the film adaptation Harold
plays a big part and is the first
creature that comes to life attacking
Tommy in a field and stabbing him with a
pitchfork from here Tommy transforms
into a scarecrow himself who will
potentially go through the same torment
that was laid upon Harold when he
himself was strung up Harold will
definitely stick with you long after you
leave the theater and the character
himself went through numerous designs
during the pre-production process of the
film including having him with his
original belly which was removed because
the filmmakers thought it made him look
friendly he also had a burlap sack
placed over his face however this was
changed to the Halloween mask that we
now see in the final cut
either way Harold is a really haunting
sight to behold and will probably make
most people think twice about crossing
paths with the Scarecrow up next is the
big toe which is one of my favorite
parts of the film this actually sticks
quite close to the source material which
centered around a boy yanking on a big
toe in his garden and pulling out of the
ground little did he know that he'd
pulled the toe off the body that was
attached to it and its owner begins to
stalk him the boy and his family all eat
the toe which is sliced up into three
pieces and similar to the film put into
a stew that night when he's asleep the
toes owner comes looking for him in his
room and eats him which happens to the
character of Oggy who in the film is
dragged out from under his bed and then
disappears never to be seen again it's a
horrifying moment that lets you know
there's nowhere to hide if you find your
name in a scary story from here we go to
the pale lady the pale lady is an
infamous Spectre that has appeared in
ghost stories over the centuries so it
makes sense that she would also be part
of the scary story saga the pale lady
made her debut in the scary story titled
the dream in which she liked the woman
with the big toe stalks her prey
menacingly in this source material she
tries to warn the character lexi morgan
to flee which is a warning that she
heeds but the sheer vision of the
creature sticks in her head long after
she comes into contact with it I think
the scariest thing about the pale lady
is the fact that she is almost
statuesque for the most part but there's
no real escape from her the facial
expressions don't display much and she
almost comes across completely oblivious
to the sheer terror that she's causing
it's difficult to make such a
slow-moving creature for your
threatening but I think the creative
team masterfully translate this to the
film and throughout it's difficult to
tell whether what's happening on screen
is real or simply a dream in the film
the creature absorbs Chuck and takes him
with her probably to a land of nightmare
and shadow hopefully the next time we
see the pale lady is in our screens and
not our nightmares as she definitely
leaves a lasting impression for all
those who've witnessed her
and finally is the jangly man an
original creature that was created
solely for the film what's so brilliant
about him is that he perfectly fits the
aesthetic of the movie and feels like a
completely natural addition to the work
the jangly man is able to build himself
from body parts and this disjointedness
to his appearance makes him seem almost
alien the jangly man appears this way
because he's put in place a torment
Ramon who lost his brother in the
Vietnam War and the severed limbs that
he displays really hit home for the
character when he makes his way to the
movie when discussing this design del
Toro said that the jangly man was
originally meant to have more limbs
attached to him to represent the body
parts returning from the war but this
would have added more workload and the
special effects which the creators
wanted to keep his practical as possible
it makes for an amazing effect and in
the end the jangly man perfectly tops up
the film with an awesome entrance that
will send shivers down your spine and
that's all of the creatures from scary
stories to tell in the dark let me know
which one is your favorite or rather
least favorite in the comments section
below and if you enjoyed this video then
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you check out my full breakdown of the
movie and where I think the story will
go in the sequels which would be linked
at the end if you want to come talk to
me about films TV shows games and comic
books then you can follow me on twitter
at definition YT it's the best way to
get in touch with me and it's the
perfect place to suggest new videos and
content so hopefully I see you over
there after this also just want to let
you know that we're giving away a free
copy of John wick 3 on blu-ray and all
you have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is to like this video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on scary stories to
tell in the dark in the comments section
below the winner will be chosen at
random on September the 10th and the
blu-ray will be shipped out from then
whoever gets the prize it's the best of
luck to everyone who takes part this is
the channel for people who are mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
you